the White House has had three three
security scares yeah
Secret Service said two people tried to
break in and one first lady tried to
break out I walked out
I want to go home this is not the deal
it's a female Schwarzenegger that's what
it is
it's come out that President Trump this
is what Trump said he said he wants the
border wall to be very tall and very
attractive that's what he said that's
what he said he also wants to replace
the wall after 10 years of marriage
see you mistress hanging on the wall you
got to keep your wall options open this
is interesting
it has also come out in the news this
was a story over the weekend that just
like President Trump even George
Washington apparently used to complain
about leaks he did he complained about
leaks there was that time Washington
said of Paul Revere fake Horseman dead
wrong about British arrival sad that's
me
did so much better than I thought it
would that's the guy just happy that
he's alive after that yesterday was the
LA Marathon yeah actually there wasn't
supposed to be a marathon people on the
405 freeway just gave up and got out of
their cars that's how it started they
got out
why would they start running now yeah
interesting story less job in a hospital
in Britain will be the first permitted
to create babies with three biological
parents yeah it's being called the
wearest experiment and british genetics
since the entire royal family
that's a rare moment of us getting to
feel happy about our system day
intermarry celebrity dish woody
harrelson revealed that he has stopped
smoking marijuana
yeah when asked when asked why Harrelson
said I don't remember
I love booing a guy's choice to stop
smoking he's gonna get eight mail now
our B's Arby's has just come out with a
venison sandwich yes the venison
sandwich is only available in Arby's
locations that are near the highway
that's a problem
you
you